sí buenas noches la de hoy ha sido una
jornada marcada por la nostalgia y por
los tributos personales de miles y miles
de personas que se han aglomerado en las
diferentes residencias oficiales
especialmente en el palacio de bukingham
aquí en el centro de londres como lo
mencionas el rey carlos tercero a dile
delineado cómo será su reinado y ya en
su primer mensaje como jefe de estado a
la nación y a los países del
commonwealth ha enviado un mensaje de
continuidad y futuro ha dicho que su
vida al igual que la de su madre la
reina isabel estará dedicada al trono al
servicio y rindió un homenaje a su madre
ha dicho que ella tenía la sensibilidad
y la habilidad de ver lo mejor en cada
persona carlos ha anunciado además que
su hijo william y su esposa kate
middleton serán ahora recibirán los
títulos de príncipe y princesa de gales
además tuvo su primera audiencia con la
primera ministra liz tras quien lleva
tres días en el cargo y a quien le
confesó que la muerte
era uno de esos momentos que estaba
atento
luisa y qué podemos esperar ya para la
jornada de mañana de este sábado
será la proclamación oficial del rey
carlos tercero el asumió inmediatamente
la reina falleció pero esta será la
proclamación oficial será en una
ceremonia que se realizará muy centrada
muy cerca de donde nos encontramos en el
palacio de saint james es luego se leerá
esa
esa ceremonia ese título en el royal
exchange de la city de londres que es el
distrito financiero de la capital
británica y por primera vez en la
historia será transmitido por televisión
lo que nos deja ver que el rey carlos
quiere modernizar la familia real
británica y también el parlamento
continuará va en su segundo día en
tributos a la reina isabel en la cámara
de los comunes que las ideologías son
bien marcadas en este caso han
coincidido los partidos en recordar y
celebrar la memoria de la reina isabel
segunda